mike florio pro football talk kind
enough to join us on easily his busiest
day of the year he starts everything off
on nbc sports on peacock and ends it
every day with pro football talk
live as well as pftpm how are you mike
i'm doing great rich how are you buddy i
am doing well what happened last night
best you can tell what happened last
night well what happened last night
in this age of analytics what do you
gain from winning what do you gain from
losing and i've been arguing for years
that
once a team knows it's out of the
playoffs there's no benefit
in winning games the benefit is in
losing games and the nfl would prefer
that there be a firewall in the minds of
fans
and plenty of fans haven't figured out
the connection
between sinking in the standings and
rising
in the draft order but that's the
incentive that's the temptation as long
as it's there
and now that we are at a time where
you've got
advanced mathematic degrees swarming all
over these nfl
front offices and everything becomes a
formula in an equation and i'm not
saying that's wrong
all i'm saying is this is a natural
outgrowth of it what do we gain from
winning the game what do we gain from
losing the game it's a no-brainer
that you at the right time make the
switch to nate sutfeld
and let nature take its course the
buccaneers did that week 17 of the 2014
season when they were leading
the saints in the fourth quarter 20-7
they took out almost all their starters
they lost the game they secured the
first overall pick
it doesn't happen a lot but it happens
i think the fact that it happened on a
national stage
the last game of the season it's a
little more special it's the hand-picked
game it's the game that's supposed to be
compelling
and you've got washington and the giants
both with direct
significance attached to it and then the
eagles just say we concede
that that's what i think is rubbing
people the wrong way and it's also
waking a lot of people up
to the fact that this is a real
temptation because i think a lot of fans
just don't understand that well i mean
the the the general sense of things um
and
the way that we now in this day and age
discern the general sense of things is
is what are people saying on twitter in
real time
uh it went from outrage to wondering
out loud if doug peterson was attempting
to get fired because
now wence is pissed because he was a
healthy scratch and hertz is
you can see him mouthing the word saying
it's not right he's now disillusioned
and
either one of those two is the future we
know nate sudfeld is not
so the question is is clearly if he's
sticking around
then we know somebody else ordered the
code red on game 256
who ordered the code red on game 256 and
is the nfl
caring to find that out mike well you
know it's funny when you talk about
peterson trying to get fired i'm
thinking well initially he tried to
spill strawberry sauce all over chuck
bed and eric's uniform then he dragged
the
super bowl trophy around the parking lot
from the bumper of his car and then he
went streaking in a body suit but
no this is this is his way of keeping
his job he knows he's keeping his job
this comes from hiring the organization
whether it's from the general manager
whether it's from the owner
this is an idea that really isn't all
that next level from uh
hey look we we look at what the jets
gave up
your jets rich three years ago to move
from six to three they gave up three
second round picks those are
key picks those could be core players
who formed the nucleus of the team for
years to come
they had to give up three second round
picks to move from six to three to get
sam darnold
that difference between six and nine is
significant and
and uh so yeah i think it came from
hiring the organization
and i think it's a sign that peterson is
safe
not that a sign that he's trying to get
out because he's going along with this
plan because the payoff is going to come
in april and beyond based upon who they
get with that sixth overall pick
and based on that his attempt to go for
it on fourth and four rather than tie
the game with a chip shot field goal was
kind of gutsy
i mean if he if if uh if hertz actually
connected on that pass they've had the
lead and the defense might have held on
to it
so my last question for you here on this
is you know the history of our league
being so involved in it for as long as
you have you know that
when uh the colts took a knee on an
undefeated regular season to keep peyton
manning safe for the playoffs
the nfl decided well here's what we're
going to do we're going to change the
schedule and jam as many
division games and game week 16 and 17
to keep
so much alive and so much important for
even the teams that have
13 and 1 14 and 1 records
uh what's the fix here is there going to
be a fix do you think for something like
this
i don't think there is a fix the league
will
say in one breath that no one tanks
because i think they want to continue
to push this idea that there's no
connection there's nothing to see here
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain because there's really nothing
they can do
and you know in the next breath the
argument is
teams can decide who they want to play
and when they want to play them and we
see
starters get rested in advance of the
playoffs we see
a guy like a tuatanga vailoa who maybe
isn't the best quarterback on the roster
but he's playing because the dolphins
want to develop him
instead of going with a guy who may be
better equipped to win football games
and ryan fitzpatrick
they're not going to second-guess that i
think going forward
the one little incremental change that
comes from this
is when the nfl is picking that that
game 256 or what next year it's going to
be game
256 plus 16. right games
but but whenever they pick that prime
time game and what will be week 18
that's going to be a factor they're
going to have to ask themselves
is the opponent going to try to win this
game i think we all assumed
the opponent was going to try to win and
that's wha i i one of the things i was
upset about is i wish i had seen it
coming
because i've been pushing this theory
for years and i rush into saying oh this
is going to be great the eagles are
going to put jalen hurts out there and i
think the eagles are going to beat them
well if i didn't know what was going to
happen
no there's no way the eagles are going
to beat them because they're not going
to try to beat them so
i just think that the nfl will look at
that
when when making those decisions late
season about what games to put in prime
time that's the major takeaway
because short of a draft lottery that
still removes all temptation to tank and
the only draft lottery that removes
temptation to tank
is to say all non-playoff teams get one
ball in the hopper oh boy
that you don't get more if you do worse
because then the temptation to tank is
still there
and unless they do something like that
the temptation to tank is always going
to be there pro football talk
live and pft pms and pro football talks
mike florio here on the road 72.
how can i not add 256 and 16 on the fly
what is wrong with you because you're
too busy
paying attention to which coach is being
hired and fired and things like that
you've got a lot of
you got a lot of plate spinning mike um
so let's start with the jacksonville
jaguars having dispatched
uh doug marone today and they've got a
ton of cap space they've got a general
manager position
and a coaching position open so you know
that entices a bunch of coaches who have
their own hand-picked general manager in
mind you also had an owner today shad
khan say that
interestingly enough he said he had
roster control for 2020 and plans to
keep it for now
how do you see all of this playing out
with trevor lawrence
also getting set to arrive for whoever
wants this job
well the widespread shatter is the it's
urban meyer's job if he wants it and the
reason that's the widespread
chatter rich is he's telling people that
he's lining up the staff
he's going to be able to hire a gm he
has reached out to potential gm's who
would join him
in jacksonville it's his if he wants it
i've heard he wants 12 million a year
which isn't all that crazy if matt
rule's getting nine million a year
right out of the gates from baylor to
carolina
and you're going to hire urban meyer to
run the show and he's as accomplished as
he is
12 million is not crazy when you
consider what coaches are making
and and and you know i thought they were
hanging on to marone until they knew
that they were going to get mired now
look this doesn't necessarily mesh with
the spirit of the rooney rule
to line up meyer before you fire marone
and then
go check the boxes on interviewing
minority candidates but
that wouldn't be the first time it's
happened and there's nothing the league
can really do about it
but it's all pointing toward urban meyer
at this point and
as of yesterday the understanding was
it's his if he wants it and the question
was
does he want it so he doesn't want the
jet job because he likes justin field so
much i mean
he doesn't want that why well
what that's going to get very
interesting that game friday night look
and i understand trevor lawrence is
regarded as a generational talent and
there's a huge gap between him and
justin fields yes
but you know if you go to jacksonville
you don't have to use that number one
overall pick you could do a flip-flop
with the jets if the jets want trevor
lawrence you get justin fields and you
pick up
more draft capital uh in the process so
you know it
it doesn't mean that he won't get fields
he doesn't have to get fields with the
first overall pick
but that's definitely going to be a
factor if he ends up in jacksonville and
this brings us all full circle which is
tank when you have the opportunity to do
it
because you don't see the jaguars did it
more subtly they go with mike glennon
instead of gardner minshew right in
16 when when it still will forget jake
gluten don't forget jake gluten james
robinson while he was banged up well
he's not going to play this week and
and it's not in prime time there's a way
to do it that isn't as obvious and i
think the jaguars were far more subtle
about it so what are the jets going to
do with their
is it joe douglas's call or they or i
haven't heard the two dreaded words of
corn and ferret yet
which normally happens uh what what
what's happening here with the jets
well the wild card is woody and johnson
because he he will be back january 21. i
didn't understand how this worked i
figured he would remain the u.s
ambassador to the uk while the
the process of confirming a successor
unfolded for career diplomats they stay
in place for political appointees
they're gone
as soon as the president who appointed
them is gone
so january 21 woody's coming back how
involved is he going to be between now
and january 21 how involved will he be
at the end will he be in on the
interviews
is he going to come back to christopher
and say can i please have back the keys
to the car that you've run into a ditch
so that's that's really the question
here and we don't know the answer to
that yet but we do know he'll be back
january 21
how active he is in the short term
remains to be seen but
so who have both of these teams lined up
to talk to because the lines are now
uh in this mix the texans are are are
obviously gotten a head start the
chargers are now
in this mix let's take it one at a time
here uh you mentioned urban for
jacksonville what about the jets how
that stands right now today's the day
where we get
the flood of names of all of the coaches
with teams that are still
in the playoffs who are being requested
permission
views so you know they we're going to
see a long list of guys
who will be interviewed the jets haven't
let it be known who they may be
targeting there's no one out there like
an urban meyer
who is lining up hey you know uh people
and making it clear that that he's got
this if he wants it so the jets haven't
given anyone the indication yet
i'm i'm fascinated by the possibility of
jim harbaugh i don't know what the
latest is on his extension it's not a
coincidence that the extension talk
bubbles up the day before the last day
of the nfl regular season
and teams have been doing their homework
on harbaugh and i know that he would not
be all that upset about possibly going
back to the nfl
and i know that woody johnson has been
smitten with him and they've thought
about him in the past
so look i i i don't know that he's the
right guy for that market
but that that's a guy that that that's
one of those that
beyond the usual subject suspects beyond
the the
lather rinse repeat candidates we're
going to hear about for all these jobs
that's one to me that i that i find
intriguing and it'll be interesting to
see how it plays out the lather lynch
rinse repeat are uh are are eric the
enemy the oc
in kansas city robert salah the dc
from san francisco um
who who are some others that that are
going to be thrown out yeah
brian dave all the bills offensive
coordinator is is coming into the mix
um and you know and sometimes the names
will surprise you like matt eberflus
there wasn't a whole lot of buzz about
him in the regular season but now he's
gotten
multiple requests he's the defensive
coordinator with the indianapolis colts
and some of these other guys you know
like i i we were expecting maybe byron
leftwich and todd bowles to be on the
list and maybe they will be
um but the the two coordinators for the
buccaneers they finish strong and
especially leftwich on the offensive
side of the ball
i'd expect him to start getting
interviews i i think that
because of the minority hiring rates
and where the league has been and what
the league is doing to try to turn it
around
there's going to be a lot of pressure on
teams to have inclusive diverse searches
that what's that's what surprised me
about this
this idea that the urban meyer cat is so
far out of the bag in jacksonville
where it looks like he's the guy i think
most teams
are going to keep their cards close to
the vest they're going to interview
a lot of guys and take their time
and not rush into it even if they
secretly
know who it is that they want to hire i
i think we're going to hear a lot of
names over the next
week or two of guys who are getting
opportunities to sit down interview for
these jobs
a few more minutes left with mike florio
pro football talk live pftpm right here
on peacock uh pro football
talk uh on digital and uh and
uh social media as well as uh the
internet so on and so forth mike florio
here on the rich eisen show
why did the chargers part ways with
anthony lynn
what about that decision well when
you've got a great young quarterback who
could be a potential transcendent talent
and if i was a dolphins fan i'd be
losing
sleep and i'd be i'd be getting
treatment for an ulcer over the fact
that they took tuatangobiloa over justin
herbert herbert's the real deal
without question and they need somebody
who's going to get the most out of him
and there's just been so many
incidents you can point to this week
where anthony lynn hasn't managed games
properly hasn't made the right decisions
that's your most important function on
game day
your you know the game plan is made your
offensive coordinator is going to handle
the offense the defensive coordinator is
going to handle the defense
and your job is to manage the whole
thing
and there are key decisions that need to
be made and when you consistently make
the wrong decision in those spots
at some point there's going to be a
change the chargers
kept their cards very close to the vest
out of respect to anthony lynn
i think they've known for weeks this is
where they were going they said nothing
to anyone they waited until today they
waited until the season was over
they probably even waited until now to
start doing any real work behind the
scenes because that word gets out as
well
once you start trying to line up
candidates and and now they go about
filling what i think is a very
attractive job because of the presence
of justin herbert and some of the other
talented players they have it they could
just keep these guys healthy
yeah on on a consistent basis the
chargers could be a great great team
so um anybody else do you think is gonna
surprise and fire somebody what do you
think what does that say well there's
always a surprise except when there is
and i think last year's surprise is
there wasn't a surprise
there was some chatter about zach taylor
enough chatter that the bengals issued a
statement this morning that he's coming
back and
you know the bengals don't like to pay
people to not work so i i never really
thought that taylor was going to get
fired
because they don't want to give the guy
a buyout now you know we
we sit and we watch and we wait there
really isn't any other spot that's
smoking
but that that's the setup for the
surprise that's that's the thing that
will happen on a tuesday night at eight
o'clock and we all say holy crap we
didn't see that coming so
so the ground is fertile rich for a
surprise
and now we just wait to see if a
surprise happens and then my last one
for you did the bears finish
the way that they finished i know that
they did they they still got boat raced
in the fourth quarter by
green bay which is just a remarkable
team
this year um did their finish and the
fact that they're in the playoffs
and you know they're going to new
orleans we'll see how that goes that was
going to be the matchup if there wasn't
a double doink a couple of years ago
um do you do you think that this is uh
uh
now i'm gonna run it back situation pace
and naggy and even
trubisky what do you think about the way
the bears finished jason i yeah rich i
think pace and nagi will be back
trubisky is to be determined based upon
what he does in the postseason
they didn't pick up his fifth year
option so he becomes a free agent unless
they sign him to a new contract
or use the franchise tag i think they
have to at least get to the nfc
championship game
before they start thinking about the
franchise tag now if the salary cap
drops to 175 million
the franchise tag values drop in a
commensurate number so
it actually can end up being cheaper to
use the franchise tag on trubisky this
year than it would have been to pick up
his fifth year option based on how low
this goes
but he's got to prove it still and
uh yeah he's going to be able to hit the
open market if hits the open market
right now i don't know that there's a
rush for his services and if the bears
want to keep him they'd be able
to sign him and bring him back if he
starts having success
in the postseason that's when the
analysis changes because now you've got
18 teams sitting at home
making their plans for next year and
they see trubisky light up the saints
and beat the saints in new orleans
you're going to feel differently about
him going forward so i think
the key is what does he do this week and
next week if there is one
but nagi and and pace i think will be
back mike appreciate the time as
always certainly on a busy day we're
gonna i would love to have you on uh
more much more often even uh this month
as
um now 18 teams it's been 20. 18 teams
have hit the non-playing season
which uh which means they're on oh
starting uh to try and get back into the
mix
lots happening i appreciate the time
mike happy new year anytime you want me
rich i i
all i'm doing sitting here typing and
talking and i can always fit it in
i appreciately greatly appreciate that
we work hard all we do is type and talk
type and talk pro football type and talk
mike florio here on the rich eyeshadow
thanks they call mike that's mike right
here
on the program at pro football talk hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here